WESLEY: Hi, and welcome to
"Serverless Migration Station,"
a serverless expedition
miniseries dedicated
to helping developers modernize
their apps to using the latest
features available to one of our
serverless compute platforms.
Today, we're
continuing our coverage
of migrating from App Engine
Task Queues to Cloud Tasks.
MARTIN: Sounds great, and
I'm so happy to be here, Wes.
Last time, in module 7, we
added App Engine Task Queues,
specifically push tasks, to
our sample App Engine NDB Flask
app.
So what are we doing today?
WESLEY: Oh, that's
right, Martin.
For those who haven't
seen the module 7 video
or completed its codelab,
please pause here to do so,
because we pick up from
where module 7 leaves off.
Today we're migrating
from App Engine
NDB to Cloud NDB and App Engine
Task Queues to Cloud Tasks.
All the links you
need are down below.
MARTIN: Now, wait, Wes.
Did you say we're migrating from
App Engine NDB and App Engine
Task Queues to Cloud
NDB and Cloud Tasks?
Isn't that two migrations?
WESLEY: That's right, Martin.
While the code will
undergo both migrations,
we're only focused on App Engine
Task Queues to Cloud Tasks,
because moving from App
Engine NDB to Cloud NDB
was already covered in module 2.
Modernizing your apps means
moving off of the legacy App
Engine services like
NDB and Task Queues
to standalone services like
Cloud NDB and Cloud Tasks.
So we're doing both
at the same time,
preparing our app to upgrade
to Python 3 next in module 9.
So for all of you, the same
drill as earlier with module 7.
If you haven't seen the module 2
video or completed its codelab,
we invite you to
pause and do that here
so you're familiar with it as
we're going to concentrate only
on Task Queues here.
MARTIN: Wow.
That's a lot of review, but
I think I'm caught up now.
WESLEY: That's great, Martin.
Now that you're
up to speed, let's
talk about what we're doing.
Remember the code
from module 7 where
we deleted all visits older
than the oldest displayed
from Datastore?
Well, we're going to
keep that functionality,
but moving the code
to Cloud Tasks.
Since it's a standalone product,
there's a little bit more setup
to do.
In addition, we're also
migrating from Engine NDB
to Cloud NDB, as
mentioned before.
MARTIN: Sounds good.
I'm going to do this by hand
while you are explaining it.
So would you please point me
to the code and the codelab?
WESLEY: Oh, for sure, Martin.
If you did the module
7 codelab, please start
with your own code base.
But if you didn't, clone the
repo or download the zip file.
We're going to start
with the module 7 code
and finish with what's
in the module 8 folder.
Here's the codelab as well,
so pause one more time
to get everything you need.
Once you're ready,
let's go to the computer
and migrate it now.
If you don't have a confirmed
working module 7 app yet,
upload to App Engine
with gcloud app deploy.
Most users watching this
video will be on Python 2.
So if that's the case, ensure
your lib folder is ready to go.
If not, or you're unsure,
delete what you have
and run pip install
so that you have it.
Confirm the app's the
same as from module 7,
whether it's your own or ours.
Once you have, then
you're ready to go.
Changes to the config files are
nearly identical to the changes
made in module 2.
We're adding use of the
Google Cloud client libraries,
and these changes include adding
required built-in packages that
go into app.yaml instead
of requirements.txt.
Now, any time built-in
libraries are used,
a few more lines
of code have to be
added to appengine_config
to point your app to them,
so make these changes as well.
Now let's do the non-built-in
libraries, like Cloud NDB.
In module 2, we added Cloud
NDB to requirements.txt.
This time we're also going to
add the Cloud Tasks library.
Python 2 users should now
delete their lib folder
and run the pip install
command to install
Flask, Cloud NDB, and Cloud
Tasks to the lib folder.
Again, these updates are
just like in module 2,
but adding both Cloud
NDB and Cloud Tasks.
Now let's move to main.py.
At the top, swap out the imports
of App Engine's Task Queue
and NDB libraries and replacing
them with the Google Cloud
equivalents.
The payload sent to Cloud
Tasks needs to be JSON encoded,
so we're going to have to
use that standard library
module as well.
Next, most cloud
libraries require a client
for each service you're using--
in our case, Cloud
NDB and Cloud Tasks.
More specifically, Cloud
Tasks requires a project ID
and an apps region along
with the queue name.
Now, this wasn't required
with App Engine Task Queues,
but recognize that
Cloud Tasks is now
a separate product that can
work with both App Engine
and not App Engine apps,
hence the extra red tape.
Fortunately, its client
provides a convenience function
named QUEUE_PATH that builds
a fully qualified path
string for us.
Be sure to swap in
your app's values
into the placeholder constants.
Now, creating a new visit and
querying the most recent visits
doesn't really change.
The only difference
is due to Cloud NDB
requiring use of its
Python context manager
when making Datastore calls.
So you'll see a new width
block containing such calls
in both store_visit
and fetch_visits.
Review the module
2 codelab and video
if you need more
information here.
For us in module 7, things get
really interesting from here
on out, meaning
that once we grab
the timestamp of the
oldest visit displayed,
we can move on.
With the App Engine
Task Queue library,
it's a single call
to create a push task
and respond back to the user.
With Cloud Tasks, it's
also a single call.
However, there's a
little bit more setup.
After logging the
oldest time stamp,
you see the necessary
payload that Cloud Tasks
needs, a flag indicating an
App Engine request, a handler
URI, JSON-encoded parameters,
and an HTTP header.
Pass this data, plus the Task
Queue path from the above,
to create task.
That's it, and the
return doesn't change.
As far as the task goes,
not much change here either.
Yes, pulling out the parameter
is slightly different.
Any Datastore code is
within a with blog.
But querying, logging, and
deletion of old entities
is pretty much the same.
There are very few changes
here because it's mostly still
the same HTTP POST method
we had in module 7.
Cloud Tasks is just an
alternative execution platform.
You really shouldn't need to
change anything in the handler.
Finally, there are no changes
to the main application handler
route.
Ensure you've made all
the updates we just
covered to your sample app.
After uploading with
gcloud app deploy,
it should run exactly
the same as before,
except now it uses Cloud Tasks.
If you're using no other
legacy App Engine services,
it is now safe to port
your app to Python 3.
Congratulations.
MARTIN: Cool.
Thanks for showing us that, Wes.
I'm surprised how similar Cloud
Tasks is to App Engine push
tasks.
Is there a guide to
help me get a better
grasp of migrating App Engine
push queues to Cloud Tasks?
WESLEY: Oh, definitely.
Below, you're going to find a
link to the specific migration
guide for moving push
queues to Cloud Tasks.
MARTIN: OK, and
while you're at it,
can you also point me to the
docs for the original App
Engine Task Queues as
well as Cloud Tasks?
WESLEY: Rest assured, my friend.
Links to both of those
are also down below.
MARTIN: Sounds good.
Usually about this
time, I ask you
what other migrations
we should look at,
but that's not the
case today, is it?
WESLEY: No, Martin, it's not.
The next step is for you to stay
tuned for module 9, where we're
going to port this module
8 app, that we just
finished looking
at, to Python 3,
including an optional
migration to Cloud Firestore.
And we look forward to having
you join us on that excursion.
This is Wesley on behalf
of Martin and Porter,
and we'll see you at that
next "Migration Station"
or on another serverless
expedition soon.
In the meantime, happy travels.
[MUSIC PLAYING]